après une semaine pénible les libéraux
était plus qu'heureux d'annoncer une
bonne nouvelle dans un événement à
saveur électorale
quel plaisir d'être avec vous ce matin
pour annoncer enfreint les compensations
accordées aux producteurs et aux
productrices de lait 1 milliards 750
millions sur 8 ans pour les producteurs
laitiers
ils recevront 345 millions en paiements
directs dès 2019 pour une ferme de 80 m
par exemple cela représente un montant
de 28 mille dollars d'ici la fin de
l'année
la ministre se défend d'avoir coordonné
l'annoncent juste à temps pour les
élections complique complexité vraiment
technique que ce soit avec le ministère
des finances avec le conseil du trésor
ben c'est ce qui explique aussi les
délais alors c'est paul échéances
électorales tant que ça dans cette ferme
familiale on bosse
la nouvelle est accueillie favorablement
mais sans enthousiasme le montant ne
couvre pas toutes les pertes et l'aide
n'est pas permanente
on a concédé des marchés avec la
promesse que il y aurait une
compensation fait qu'on peut progresser
là dessus mais c'était pas notre premier
choix mais la menace est surveillé
patate moins rose que qui était bloqué
le président laisse aucun bail des
représentants de l'industrie laitière
exige la fin des brèches dans le système
de la gestion de l'offre pour l'avenir
accessoirement contraint d'arrêter de
donner notre marché aux autres s'ils
sont élus les conservateurs
maintiendrait les compensations
annoncées par les libéraux mais un
douche il les accuse de s'être traîné
les pieds
d'autant que l'ampleur de l'aide
concernant le nouvel accord canada etats
unis mexique n'est pas encore connue le
chef conservateur reproche à justin
trudeau de laisser planer l'incertitude
pour le bloc québécois
'l'annonce des libéraux est
essentiellement un calcul politique ça
donne de l'espoir aux entrepreneurs
agricoles et ça on peut paraître qu'on
soit je suis pour ça on oublie tout le
monde a eu je suis content merci parce
qu'on est à la prochaine élection
chaussures un peu ordinaire pour
rassurer les producteurs le gouvernement
s'engage à protéger le secteur laitier
lors de futures négociations
commerciales
au delà de la stratégie électorale cette
annonce permet aussi aux libéraux de
relégué à l'arrière plan la sphère
snc-lavalin du moins pour un moment ici
louis blouin radio canada ottawa